doing new things  with your partner that if you do the  things that you enjoy  that's really nice that's comfortable  that's cozy that solidifies the  friendship but if you want to create  intensity it  it demands risk taking doing new things  outside of your comfort zone a little  bit more on the edge how often should we  be doing new things with our different  partner  i think as often i mean look the answer  to this is very simple  often enough  but not too often that you become  chaotic and you disregulate right now  you're asking me a systemic question  this is true for an individual a  relationship or a company if you  don't change  or grow  you fussilize and you die  if you change too much too fast no  stability there's no stability you go  chaotic and you dysregulate